hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I will present the marble color puzzle I
have three blue marbles and three red
marbles underneath one Bowl I'll place
two of the blue marbles underneath
another Bowl I will place new red
marbles and underneath the final ball
I'll place the remaining one red and one
blue marble now I'm going to pick one of
these bowls at random so I'll spin them
around so I don't know which Bowl has
which marbles and I'll just pick
whichever ball ends up in front of me so
we'll go ahead and pick this bowl that's
in front of me I'm randomly going to
pick one of the two marbles that's under
this bowl so I've picked out a red
marble and here's the puzzle what is the
probability that the other marble in
that bowl is also red try and figure out
the answer I will post the solution next
week on Monday I hope you like this
video please subscribe to my channel you
can get my books listed on my website
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on Twitter at pressure Locker and you
can support me on patreon